[Music]
kourtney kardashian's daughter penelope
is taking after mom's new boyfriend
travis barker that could be really cute
on thursday courtney shared these
moments to instagram
showing travis and penelope jamming out
on a drum set
[Music]
the blink 182 drummer later shared this
video to his instagram story
featuring proud mom courtney watching
penelope at the helm of
yup another drum set
travis wrote happy birthday penelope
alongside the tribute video
courtney kicked off a special day with
this photo of her and the birthday girl
still in bed
later in the day the reality star shared
this pic
and wrote my birthday girl my favorite
girl in the entire world
i am so happy and proud to be your mommy
i cannot believe that you are nine
my life is so much better because of you
and travis is turning out to have quite
the musical influence on the family
on wednesday travis shared this video to
instagram where courtney proved
she could keep up with her man at the
piano
travis jokingly wrote next to the video
album coming soon
followed by courtney commenting my heart
and soul
last month we also saw courtney and
travis locking lips in the recording
studio
she even accompanied travis to an
impromptu jam sesh in venice beach
where he played a surprise rooftop
concert with machine gun kelly